المثل المراه لازم اذا مثلا مع احترامات
لك تخون الزوج لازم نجي الهيابه
جزاك الله الف خير
[موسيقى]
يعني قضيه قتل المراه بدوافع الشرف ما
يسمى بالنسبه للقضاء العشائري انا اللي
اقوله فقط اتساءل هو الانسان كائن المراه
كائن بشري اذا كانت طعن في شرفها ليش
الرجل من يتصرف تصرفات مهينه وايضا لا شرف
ليش ما يحاسب ايضا ليش المراه تحاسب
انطيني ليش ليش هذا التمييز في هذا الواقع
ليش
من الايام اتكلم على الاسلام ايش قال قال
الاسلام يرجم المراه وكذا وكذا قلت له راح
بس اجاوبك اجابه واحده لو رجل تزوج بامراه
واربعه وعشرين ساعه قايم لها بالخدمه و24
عام يكد على اطفالهم ليسوا باطفالهم
بالاصل هاي المراه ما تستحق تقتل
الاسلام جرم المراه اذا محصنه ترجع شهوه
الله جرمها انا ما جرمها مراه اللي تخون
الزوج تقتلها العشاء يمكن حتى قانونك
العراقي اذا قضيه الشرف ما اعتقد انه
ينسجن سته شهور يطلع هو فقط يقتله يقتل
نفس بشريه حتى ان يرفع راسه والعقال يكون
مال
ته على هم دائما يتصورون